thank you
[Music]
all right in uh in some more Japanese
news oh great yay uh there's something
curate this just because of Steve
Toronto dude yeah I think so he's fourth
generation Japanese
should be giving a Camarillo outlet news
oh uh so Sapporo Japan you know that
that yeah the beer Burger there's also a
place there's something
Wicked going on in this place oh no with
the beer factory not in the beer factory
the city Sapporo just in the public
restrooms of this city
they're throwing it down bro was it
wasn't there a story we did about I got
like people in Japan where um asking to
use like other businesses their bathroom
and they would be like nah you can't go
in there because they're worried they're
just gonna jack off in the bathroom
yeah we did a story here
and then Joe was like yeah that's a
[__] thing yeah
Joe was like yeah that's the thing that
happens so I'm assuming that's what it
is they're worried they're gonna judge a
thing
[Laughter]
it's not that something's being stolen
from public restrooms in toilet paper
and that's not toilet paper something
little urinal cakes
you know how like the little pink urinal
cake thing how there's like a screen
around it that looks like a like a like
a cup yeah uh they're taking that why
taking the urinal eye what's the
material oh yeah what what's the
material buddy is taking every single
one of those arrows because you gotta
touch that that's disgusting maybe
that's his Kink yeah that's the thing so
like here's the funny thing authorities
say they have no idea why someone would
do that
I think I think they know exactly why
someone would do that why they're going
home to lick it yeah come on
yeah what are you you guys
you guys were 30.
I love how Japan is so safe that this is
their like
serial killer crime yeah it's like who's
stealing all the urinal cakes right
because out here don't just be like oh
buy a new one
would you guys argue the usage or the
effectiveness of urinal kicks do you
guys think they really work
I think they are I think they smell good
yeah you know what I always wondered I
think they smell good I'll [__] say
it confidently oh you're gonna say I
don't think it matches the volume of
piss that goes into it you gotta aim
what is it made of does it mean that
like just wax uh yeah wax
still smell like [__] because so many
pissed so much pisses going yeah um but
they have like the little like finger
things coming out right is that what
you're talking about like how it's like
textured is that what you're talking
about sometimes they have a little
shapes sometimes this little cat yeah I
guess they could be they could have the
variety you could get a variety pack
with five different ones if you're gonna
show me a photo because I have like
three different images in my mind
you don't we don't show you a photo you
show us a photo you draw it right now
all right have you ever have you know
have you ever smelled a urinal cake no
dude I've been in a women's bathroom
you've never been in a men's bathroom so
like when you go it doesn't Splash back
so you're not gonna Splash Zone okay
take it yeah yeah like see that blue one
at the end that's the common one and
then you got your like little flare
versions that are for the show yeah yeah
some are for special occasions some of
them don't work it splashes you back
yeah you know what your urinals they
have blue piss on you it's basically so
the purpose is so that stuff doesn't
clog up the you know but then also
usually there's a built-in air freshener
in it which is kind of made of the same
thing that you put like on the side of
the toilet sticking your face in it and
smelling it once all right don't make
that my whole thing
so uh funny thing is like what do you
think the odds are that there is no
Bandit but really
one bathroom stole from the other and
then that guy stole from the other to
replace it's just going in a [__]
Circle I bet that's very likely that's
the real
crime that's my theory oh why because I
don't want to believe Japanese are
perverts oh they're the biggest ones I
start branding it then so you get your
custom like daikokuia
you're an okay Ramen cake and then and
then if that's
they're like yo why does this yoshinoy
restaurant have a [__] daikoku yeah
yeah take a few little marks on the
bottom yeah that's true it might also
just be kids bro you think kids are a
little mischievous and they just want to
steal stuff I don't I think kids change
it up yeah I don't think they would
dedicate this much time and effort to
stealing over 30 like oh that's a lot
somebody in Sapporo has a home full of
these and it's just like
he's a diabolical Thief Rock Solid yeah
it's a it's a kinky thing I mean in my
heart of hearts yeah
dude he has a urinal at home and he's
like
better to just steal
see that Thursday is less Japanese to me
yeah then a guy that goes love the smell
that's just practical yeah that that
might be Chinese
is that still the napkins from the
restaurant
maybe I need the cakes too because then
you need a wholesale account to buy the
little urinal holders you know yeah
nobody has that Japanese don't steal for
money they steal for perversion so
you're right who can just you know never
run out so that's what it looks like
when it's in the urinal Colleen in case
you uh so that's the one of the images
that I was thinking in my head so it's
not
it's not really a sexy image off the bat
no no I you know that was not what I was
thinking do you like the color of the
blue I mean the texture right if you
actually touched it it's just such a
bizarre thing to steal yeah yeah
yours are kind of nasty murals are
disgusting bathroom related you know
what though you know how like in Japan
it's not like here where you have to
like protect everything from meth heads
and all this security and whatever like
it's just a normal bathroom like when
you go into the park or whatever it's
just like everything's just normal like
you just got even bidets sometimes right
yeah there's so many things that you can
vandalize take or whatever but it's just
out there in the open yeah I think like
that might start to change because a lot
of people are starting to [__] with a
lot of stuff just because because
they're just bored yeah like now you
know those boys are going around the
rotating sushi things and just licking
the sushi
he got in big trouble you see that
that's why these kids and you get their
ass he got like a 200 000 fine or
something good making an example yeah
because it's like basically a
terroristic action it's just like yeah
it's bioterrorism but also they a lot of
the rotating places they lost business
and they're like I don't know you know
about this stuff yeah all right so they
got a quote from a 69 year old resident
to get his opinion on this and he says I
want you to stop stealing in the toilet
in public places
it's like uh it's one of those things
coming out there is pretty fire oh
really yeah and Sapporo they have their
own style what's the style I don't know
covered beer
I did see a diagram around the diagram
oh 10 different styles as you go down
the country like they're like every
place has its own unique style yeah I
don't know what the style is but like
the region has its own style like creamy
there's like over 10 of them some of
them are more like pork heavy some of
them is like chicken heavy like broth or
like yeah did you see that there was a
you know the guy that's uh I guess he
was like the original host of Iron Chef
he he said a statement that made
everybody like it was like a click bait
statement basically but he said Sushi's
not Japanese what and then all these
people like what and then you read
further and it's like
JK yeah he said that like sushi has
spread out in a diaspora throughout so
many regions of the world that it kind
of takes on different forms and it's not
considered to be Japanese like Japanese
don't claim that the sushi in Germany is
Japanese sushi Mexico German Sushi you
know it's yeah Mexican sushi like a
California roll right yeah which is cool
that they're like opposite from Italians
you know yeah it has to be Nepali it has
to be this way right right right right
where there's like what is it those
viral videos of Italians freaking out
about how you eat like a pasta or
something oh no and then they're like
oh but I like that uh I like that it is
kind of cool for them to to accept that
to be like yeah you know it is gonna
evolve and change and that is your
rendition very logical I think um what I
learned about the Japanese cooking stuff
is that whatever they find is like
traditional or whatever that's supposed
to be like there's a method for that ah
but ramen's not Japanese actually what
is it it's Chinese it's not even a
Japanese word it's La Meen or whatever
that's the it's a Chinese word yeah yeah
we got it we got it so technically
there's no rules it's like
it could be made however it's just it's
just soup what about sushi though
because that guy was talking about sushi
she's sushi sushi does have that but
it's also I don't know I think like
certainly forever Japanese bro are more
traditional and they have like a strict
way of preparing it and doing it yeah
but there's also so many [__] regions
there that do it their own way like
Japan kind of just does like Fusion
stuff anyways if you look at like French
pastries and then you just and they're
Italian food super good their time is
really good the Japanese people are so
good at everything they just kind of
take it they don't invent them two
actually a couple a couple different
friends have gone to Japan recently and
they're like I had the best pizza in
Japan they make pizza pretty fire you
know what I'm saying it's like they're
they're just kidding before them they're
just trading like if you take my Sushi I
get to have our pizza yeah or they're
just like this is how they do it I'm
just gonna make it this way or make it
better and I think that's just the
Japanese way they're all like Craftsmen
they just kind of Tinker away and like
make it their own I mean if they're
gonna put Wasabi on KitKat and like
they're probably not like Nazi about
their food yeah seriously Wasabi on
KitKat there's what's up
wow so the kitkats are off the rails
right now I thought a strawberry KitKat
was crazy but I do see the rigidness
though in their own Camp so like let's
say there's like a like a Giro style of
making sushi then if you're unlearning
under this master then you gotta do it
under their technique you think they're
too loyal or I think the way I see their
apprenticeship system is like
Renaissance Italy where like back then
the system was like you Apprentice under
a master and you learn their art and
then eventually when they pass it to you
you're continuing that art so that's
kind of how I see their style and their
job is to keep it as like the same as
their if you're learning that style they
probably built the whole brand up yeah
like that's my brand it's that style so
you wanna push that thing on but then
like I don't see them really beat like I
don't know this isn't just me but from
what I know about the food culture out
there is I don't see them saying you're
not doing it yeah you know I kind of
worried about their own [__] how they're
making it better huh
I see it within their own schools of
thought this is our traditional way
my stereotype about Japanese people is
that they're just good at everything
especially if they're producing if
somebody is uh making something and they
happen to be Japanese I'm like that's
probably good [__] that's how I feel
is that racist I don't know J-pop K-pop
K-pop is a little better than your
Japanese I've never even heard from Zen
Buddhism a monk that is k-pops from
zenburg
no the the reason why everyone deep
dives into the [__] that they do yeah uh
this monk said express yourself through
your work so like it's like instead of
like buying [__] to show off or whatever
like real
personal expression is through whatever
your craft is yeah so if you're like a
mug maker make the best [__] mug and
then this is like how you show your like
whatever or like it's like ASMR [__]
right like that's also Buddhism or Zen
style so like when they make
um free food it's like I'm giving you a
piece of me yeah look at this so you
have that experience it's visual sense
also like smell and taste and even like
the way they clean up it's like if your
janitor be the best [__] janitor and
then do it it's religious yeah yeah that
really may be the motivation behind this
guy this guy's the best feeling the
urinal case that's not the best [__]
maybe he's the Dexter of stealing the
[__]
foreign